Magnus Carlson just completed chess with
countless tournament wins the World Cup
was the only prominent one missing for
Magnus until now the final match was
against The Talented Rising Star Ramesh
Babu pragna ananta at just 18 years old
he was the youngest finalist in World
Cup history it was also magnus's first
time in the final after both classical
games were drawn the match went to Rapid
tie breaks in the first tiebreak Magnus
maneuvered his Knights to suffocate
White's King he then slid his Rook to A3
to attack the bishop and threaten
Checkmate low on time and his position
having collapsed Prague resigned the
second tie break was a draw which was
enough to Crown Magnus Champion of the
World Cup in the post-match interview
Magnus had this to say finally now with
these youngsters we have a generation
that's worthy of successing us when the
time comes and the time could be fairly
soon afterward he shared this to social
media
and that's how